the murder trial of Alec Murdoch
continues in South Carolina this has
been an almost all day Affair we are
going to get some reaction here from the
table and I want to start with Judge
Jeanine of course but before I do can I
just play three things that are
significant and have you react to them
and walk us through what actually
happened today and how this plane is
going to land to steal a phrase okay
this is him earlier today one of the
first things he says when he denies
killing the wife and son ever most of
all
I'm sorry to Max
and Powerball
I would never
intentionally do anything
to hurt either one of them
ever
okay and then there's another one judge
where he talks about lying to the cops
let's get that one
did you lie to agent Owen and agent
Croft on the follow-up interview I did
lie to them
did you lie to them by telling them that
you were not down at the Kennels
on that night yes so why would he lie
this is what he said
Alec why did you lie
say to Owen agent Croft and Deputy
Rutland about the last time you saw
Maggie and Paul
as my addiction evolved over time
I would get any situations or
circumstances where I would get paranoid
thinking all right judge help us
understand what we learned from that
early part today okay a couple of things
uh in this case Murdoch had to take the
sand the evidence is stacked against him
uh but the issue was how do you
personalize a monster they put him on
the stand he's one of the best Witnesses
I've ever seen on a witness stand he's
had a lot of reason to react to the
Pitbull D.A here and he hasn't reacted
but let's talk about his saying sorry to
Max and papa I didn't intentionally uh
uh murder uh or whatever the actual
statement is I didn't intentionally
murder uh anything or to hurt either one
of them okay so why does he use the word
intentionally well you could say he's a
lawyer you could say he's speaking in
terms of how the indictment is written
murder is an intentional crime but it is
prefaced with uh I am sorry to mags and
Paul all right that means he's basically
admitting to them you know I'm sorry I
didn't intentionally do anything to hurt
you what he is doing there is brilliant
he is creating the premise for a down
charge that means that even though he's
charged with intentional murder there is
evidence when the defense goes in to
have a discussion with the judge about
what the jury will be charged the the
defense will say we want manslaughter in
there and the judge will say there's no
evidence that manslaughter defense will
say yes there is he said he didn't
intentionally hurt either one of them so
that was a very big moment in the
cross-examination now he had to admit
the lies he had to admit it which is the
same reason he had to take the stand
there is corroboration of virtually
everything that puts him at the scene
puts his voice on at the scene the jury
has no question other than that guy did
it so they personalized this monster
they have him on there when you listen
to the 911 sounds like he's in tears
then you look at him he's in tears and
you say to yourself well you know the
truth is maybe he's not so bad the
prosecutor is coming across as a pit
bull which is good except this guy knows
exactly how to handle the prosecutor oh
all right so I'm screaming yeah
what's going on there it looks like the
pit bull is going out there Tyrus your
thoughts today as you watch this you've
um it's been enjoyable to listen to the
commentary off camera yeah well I'm not
repeating that but uh you know I look at
this and and the pit bull as you call
him he was leaning to the side with his
hand in his pocket that was that was
pretty powerful to me like he was all up
in his space and that's when you uh when
you're trying to Razzle someone you're
trying to mess with somebody you get in
their space classic Waters move as we
preface something that Jesse does with
some of his investigation you know uh
I'm kind of old school I'm before I pass
a judgment I'm going to wait and see
what the jury has to say because really
what he's doing is I think he's trying
to just reach one juror and by giving
the pawpaw and giving the names and
trying to be human and admitting that
he's a lot of things he's a liar he's a
drug addict he's all these things but
he's not a killer and I think uh he's
doing I hate to say it but he's he's
doing a good job of it because he had me
going oh man I mean maybe
yes sorry Pierce yeah what do you think
Pierce
well you want to know how the plane land
in my estimation
guilty as charged he I've just spent
last week in preparation to work with
Jesse I went down to in Village space
Jesse I went down to I went to Texas and
Missouri to go into maximum security
prisons and interview serial killers uh
it just got me in the right frame of
mind for working with him
um and I've done a lot of these in it
for a series coming on Fox Nation that
in the year so I spent a lot of time
across psychopath lions and he's a
psychopathic liar this guy is the George
Santos of psychopaths he did this I
think he didn't just kill the wife and
the son he also killed the housekeeper
she just accidentally fell over and died
come on uh this guy is a serial killer
and he's maybe doing a good job on the
stand but you cannot tell me to us you
are one of the smartest people I know in
America you're falling for this no I'm
not I I love to watch narcissists work
they always try to outsmart everyone and
I I enjoy watching that what I am trying
to say is the one thing that bothers me
is everyone always comes out guilty
guilty during the process and then lo
and behold one juror Finds A Reasonable
Doubt and then I'll help you explain
look just take the WhatsApp video alone
that's it to me he's there he's there
right when this all happens and then he
lied about it that why'd you have to go
any further I believe he's there I
believe he's politely trying to say he
was high all the time
prove to you beyond a reasonable doubt
that he killed them because he was there
at what point it proves that he has lied
through his back and he admitted about
being there when this all went down
which says to me along with all the
other rivers he'd just been told he was
up to his neck in financial sleaze he
was gonna have the book thrown at him he
had all this other stuff going on he's
lied to every single person he's ever
been with if he's going to have the book
thrown at him why kill your wife well I
don't know the precise motive for why he
kills his wife and son and that's the
issue I agree that doesn't policy
because that's what happens I think
that's the most reality did not have an
insurance policy on her or the son let
me tell you the reason the reason is the
wife had seen a matrimonial attorney six
weeks before and talk about a perfect
storm they would get a forensic
accountant and then all of his crimes
would come out if he gets rid of the
wife in a matrimonial then you're no
doubt that he did it right I have no
doubt right and then right before we
came on Jesse the Pitbull prosecutor was
going through the financials and saying
did you take this money did you borrow
this money and he's talking about the
Habit that he had his opioid habit
um and there were millions of dollars
that he was not just borrowing but
stealing so Mr Waters no relation is
trying to establish that this guy is
conniving he is heartless he's
manipulative and he's methodical and he
will steal from children even
and the fact that you would do that
shows what he's capable of and shows his
motivation he is a greedy guy so they're
trying to establish ruthless greed
and for someone that's been following
this trial from the very beginning
[Music]
of the afternoon
I am impressed by this Psychopathic
serial killer and if that makes me a bad
person so be it his posture on the stand
is perfect he is leaning forward he
looks sad he's unflappable and he's
taking just enough issue with the
prosecution to make him look aware of
his dark history but not too aware
so he's creating the perfect amount of
haze and fog so he doesn't have to go
into too much detail listen so can you
use that and I think he's guilty right
to use the George Santos energy one more
time Santa's when I interviewed him on
Monday admitted to a series of lesser
lies because he knew it was
incontrovertible and he wanted to think
he's a little Fibber not a massive
Whopper perpetrator but in fact he's a
massive Whopper perpetrator this guy
wants us to think look I'm a bad guy I
fiddle with money I rip everybody off I
lie to everybody but I could never kill
someone remember he's a lawyer
they want me to play Call for number
four and get the judge's reaction this
is about the whether he changed clothes
remember what you changed into
do I remember yeah yeah I know I changed
clothes and I I've learned since then
what I had on but I don't you don't
remember okay I don't remember that at
all
but I understand I had on athletic
shorts and a t-shirt
all right judge convenient number one
convenient you don't remember that that
way it doesn't have to answer what he
had on should have blood spatter on it
and that's where they were going with
that I don't know what clothing that is
so whether or not they have that
clothing but I wanna I wanna say one
thing to you about lying yeah as a judge
I would say to the jury you are free if
you believe the defendant has lied about
one thing to assume he's lied about
everything but you cannot make the jump
from a non-credible witness to a
murderer but you can assume once he
takes a stand that he lied to you about
what he said and what he did yeah I have
a quick question one of the things he
did I think is particularly clever he
would not implicate his partner yes he
kept saying I did it on my own my
partner had nothing to do with it he was
an honest guy so he's literally trying
to show like he's a lot of things and at
the same time he still has Integrity
like that's what he's trying like my you
know I think that goes a long way
because he does he's not taking it it's
like wow he's willing to take the rap
for this and not spare his partner who
apparently wants to Russell return to
the trial so we will do that and maybe
you'll see us again watch out I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now